Ladies and gentlemen, welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is Tim Ferriss.
What you're about to hear is part two
of a two part conversation with Ramit
Sethi.
He is an entrepreneur,
he's tried venture backed now he's
going self funded, bootstrapped.
He is a behavioral change and persuasion
expert and also a very good friend of
mine.
If you didn't catch the first part,
you might want to do that before
venturing in. If you don't mind,
your stories is more of a jigsaw puzzle,
then by all means keep on listening and
we tend to bounce around quite a lot.
So I think that you could almost listen
to them in reverse order and still get a
lot out of it.
But for the background context and so on.
Part one has a lot of that.
This episode is brought to you
by the Tim Ferriss Book Club,
a handful of books that have had a huge
impact on my life and keep in mind that
I read three to four
books a week on average.
So these are four to six that have
really made a huge difference.
Check them out@audible.com forward
slash Tim's books, audible.com,
forward slash Tim's books. And if you
would like to join me, Richard Branson,
Seth Godin and some other amazing folks.
I'm not calling myself amazing,
but those people aren't
managing, uh, on Necker Island,
which is Richard Branson's private
island for a week of mentorship. Uh,
it's going to be amazing.
Check out shopify.com forward slash Tim,
that's Shopify, s h o p, I
f y.com, forward slash Tim.
And now without further ado,
please enjoy part to the final part of
the Tim Ferriss show with Ramit Sethi.
My hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living
now.
So
the revenue per email,
I'm your quintessential case of
reticence to monetize. Right?
And of course I've been,
I've been ridiculed for years by many
friends because of this, which is fine.
My general approach to date has been,
it's either free or it's really,
really high end and very expensive. Uh,
and I think a good example of that was
Ota opening the Kimono that that event
that I said was going to be one time,
and at least to date it has only been
one time and it was depending on when
people sign up.
It was between $7,500 and $10,000 a seat
and it's sold out from one blog post.
And I remember I was talking to
someone about event management,
somebody who does this for a living.
I mean someone who's putting on events
once a quarter making a lot of money from
the events or or so I thought,
and I asked her at one point what she
would do to fill an event with between a
hundred and say 20 and 200 people at
this given price point. She said, well,
you're going to have to hire a full
time person to do, to falling 12 things.
You're probably going to have to pay
for the following type of marketing and
outbound and this and that.
And the other thing and all
it took was one blog post.
And now the way I explain that is that
I've given away so much free content and
value,
hundreds of books worth of content on
the blog that I've established a level of
trust with my audience so that when
I finally offer something for sale,
the understand and assume I've given
it a lot of thought, which is true.
Do you think that's a foolish approach?
No,
I think it's great.
I mean I give away 98% of my material
for free and then for many of my flagship
courses,
they're extremely expensive if I tend
to 100 times what my competitors charge.
So I love the idea. In fact, I'll
even take it one step further.
You know a lot of times people,
they would come to me and say like,
that's ridiculous.
Maybe if it were $30 and I just smiled
because I don't play in the $30 sandbox,
I don't want to play there.
I'd rather give it to you for free.
Then play in the $30 sandbox.
And I think it's very important when you
think about pricing and positioning is
very important to think.
What does this mean for you?
It's the same reason where if you go to
the farmer's market and you see a guy
selling a tee shirt,
you know he's selling it for 25 bucks and
you go in there and say, I'll give you,
I'll give you $3.
Look,
the guys probably still making a profit
on $3 but why is he going to laugh you
out of his store and just
turn his back on you? Why?
Because he doesn't want
to play in the $3 sandbox.
And he would rather just say a blanket,
no,
then even make a small amount of revenue.
So I really love the idea of
giveaway as much as you can for free,
but don't be afraid to aggressively sell.
We are unapologetic about how aggressive
we are because we've done the testing
and we know that it works. So we sell at
high price points and we sell, you know,
when we sell. And, um, I mean,
I could share stories of how we've
done that and all that stuff,
but I think you should be
unapologetic about that.
And, um, so, so let's take
her to take a real case then,
something that I've been considering,
but I've been very hesitant about,
and I've been considering
this for a long time.
I know you probably kind of laughing to
yourself because every time we meet up,
I'm like, you know, I've
been thinking about this.